they expected me to be wonderful to
offer me a job like this and i wasn't
wonderful
and therefore i realized new principle
because i'm not responsible what other
people think i'm able to do
i don't have to be good because they
think i'm going to be good
and somehow i could relax about this and
i thought to myself i haven't done
anything
important well i'm never going to do
anything important
but i used to enjoy physics and
mathematical things and because i used
to play with it it was never very
important
but i used to do things for the fun of
it so i decided i'm going to do things
only for the fun of it
and only that afternoon when i was
eating lunch some
kid threw up a plate in the cafeteria
which has a blue medallion on the
plate the cornell sign in the cafeteria
and as he threw up the plate and it came
down
it wobbled and the blue thing went
around
like this and i wondered it seemed to me
the blue thing went around faster than
the wobble
and i wondered what the relation was
between the two see i was just playing
no importance at all so i played around
with the equations of motion of
rotating things and i found out that if
the wobble is small
the blue thing goes around twice as fast
as the wobble
goes around and then i tried to figure
out if i could see why that was
directly from newton's laws instead of
through the complicated equations and i
worked that out for the fun of it
and then i went to hans beta and i said
hey by the way i show you
something amusing and i explained this
to him
and he said to me that's very amusing
and interesting he said but what is the
use of it what
i said that doesn't make any difference
hasn't any use i'm just doing it for the
fun of it
and then bob wilson who was the head of
the nuclear lab there the same bob
wilson
had some kind of instinct or something
because it was that the same day or
other
that he called me and he told me that
when they hire a professor at the
university
it's their responsibility what the
professor does and it's their risk and
if he doesn't do anything or he doesn't
accomplish anything it's not his thing
to worry about that
they're taking the risk to put him in
the environment and i should do whatever
i want
amuse myself or whatever i want so with
that double combination
i could relax somehow i was getting out
from some psychological problem
and i relaxed and started to play played
as i said with the rotation
this rotation led me to the problem a
similar problem of the rotation of the
spin of an electron
according to dirac's equation and that
just led me back into quantum
electrodynamics which is the problem
i've been working on
and i kept i kept continuing now to play
with it
in the relaxed fashion i had originally
done and everything
it's just like in a cork out of a bottle
everything just poured out
i by the way in a very short order
worked the things out for which i
later won the nobel prize